when learning about recursion it can
seem like you're always going back to
the beginning
in this course the simple engineer will
help you understand
recursion using animations thought
processes
and more hey guys and welcome to another
video brought to you by the simple
engineer
in today's video we are going to delve
deep into the depths of recursion
and strengthen your algorithmic mental
model
around this programming paradigm we'll
do so by looking at a variety of
different examples and animations
so let's get right into it
[Music]
the first question that we have to
answer about recursion is
what even is recursion and i think the
best way to talk about it is through
this
analogy and let's imagine that you're
sitting in line waiting to withdraw
money out of an atm
and for the sake of this example let's
assume that this right here is you and
you have this
question this underlying question and
you want to know
how many people are standing in front of
you in this line
and this kind of brute force iterative
version of you
says well what i can do is i could step
out of line i could run to the front
and i could maybe maybe count one by one
and maybe i
store these counts in some auxiliary you
know
notebook that i have some external
variable
that you can imagine and then you run
down this line and you get back and you
say okay i got my answer but i did a lot
of
work and we want to kind of switch this
paradigm we want to think how can i be
lazy what's the least amount of work
that i can do
and sort of break this problem down in
some sort of sub structure and so what i
do
well i tap on this girl's shoulder in
front of me and i ask her a very simple
question i say hey what number are you
and she turns around and looks at me and
says you know i'm sorry i don't really
know
but what i'll do is i'll ask the woman
in front of me
and what happens is this process kind of
continues
and it continues up until we hit some
stopping condition
and this condition that we get stopped
at is when we hit this woman and she
taps on this guy's shoulder
and he says she says hey what number are
you in line
and he gives this response and he's
number one
and this is interesting right because
this is kind of the stopping condition
to this sort of problem that we were
solving
and what she does is she takes that
number and she says well
if he was number one then i'm basically
one plus one because i count myself
and this guy says well if she was number
two then i'm one plus whatever she was
and this idea unravels backwards to the
original asker
and this woman basically says to the guy
hey there were
you know 10 people in front of me i
count myself
and now i'm at 11. and it turns
out that we can model this problem
with this simple blueprint we ask the
first question what's the least amount
of work that i can do how do i break
this problem down into some sub problem
and the second question that i have is
when would the process complete like
what's my stopping condition
and in this case it's when we hit the
first person in line which is the
gentleman
withdrawing money from the atm
it just so happens that we can actually
write this problem
in a very simplified minimal beautiful
piece of code
and the function that we have is just
this get my position in line and
we have this kind of abstraction of a
person that we have
and notice the return value is an
integer and
again if we think back to those two
questions that we have for this
blueprint
we say if the next person in line is
null then we must be the first person in
line
right that's kind of this base case
imagine nobody is in line
well then you're probably the first
person in line now if we don't satisfy
this conditional
then what do we do we do just a little
bit of work we say i'm going to count
myself
as somebody that contributes to the
number of people in line
and i'm going to add this kind of
recursive call and i'm calling myself
and this is the interesting property of
recursion we're calling our self
but the parameter that we condition on
actually further progresses us
to the problem that we're trying to
solve and so i'm not i'm not passing
the same person object into the function
again
i'm actually passing a person that
progresses me a little bit closer
to the question that i'm asking which is
how many people are in front of me
and this is really all recursion is
about it's how can i take some large
problem
and break it down into a bunch of sub
problems such that each invocation of my
method
gets me a little bit closer to the
problem that i'm trying to solve
let's think about another example let's
take back to the the school days where
you're writing a bunch of essays and and
typically this process
at least for me is you know you write an
essay you submit it to your professor
and he says hey
you know that essay was terrible i want
you to go make revisions
and the essay gets passed back to the
student and this process can actually
continue over and over and over again
you write an essay you make revisions
you submit it it gets denied and you
rinse and repeat
and you do this until the professor says
okay that was good i'm going to put it
into my briefcase and start grading it
and it just so happens this again is
this kind of recursive
strategy that can be developed if we
look at a simple piece of code
and what are we doing we're really we
look at an essay we revise the essay we
read it
we get feedback on it we apply changes
to it
and then notice we just call ourselves
again
right and there's a single base case
kind of hidden in here and we do it
until the essay is complete
and notice that each invocation is the
same essay object but what we've done is
we've inched our way a little bit closer
to that goal
that goal of no longer needing revisions
on the essay
so the whole process again just to
reemphasize is that we do a little bit
of work
on each invocation of our method call
until we hit some base case some
stopping condition that says
hey you no longer need to continue
so again like what is recursion
recursion is nothing more than a method
that calls itself and to be more precise
it's usually a method that maybe returns
a value maybe it doesn't
but it's conditioned on some parameter
such that when you hit
some conditional at some point in time
you can actually stop recursing some
base case
right and we consider this piece the
base case this is the stopping condition
such that we no longer grow the number
of recursive calls that we're storing in
memory
and this piece down here this is the
recursive call this is where i
you know i do some unit of work some
small
sub problem that inches me or progresses
me closer
to the goal or question i'm trying to
answer
before we dive into the technical
intricacies of recursion it's important
that we discuss some of the trade-offs
why would we want to use recursion and
why would we want to avoid recursion
and i think there are valid examples for
both and it really comes down to the
situation
the first pro that i'll give is that
really bridges the gap between elegance
and complexity
we will look at a variety of different
problems where we're traversing
complex data structures like trees and
graphs and it really boils down to three
or four lines of
code and that is vastly different
than doing something like that in this
kind of imperative approach where
we're looking at things with a lot of
loops and a lot of variables and that
can get really messy really quickly
with data structures that are inherently
recursive
now on the downside you know adding a
bunch of
method calls on the call stack incurs
some cpu overhead right there is some
slowness
with calling methods in your code
compared to
iterating through a loop and that again
is another trade-off you need to make
it can be a time or space trade-off that
you need to consider
now i touch on this briefly but again
like
recursion can reduce the need for
complex loops
and auxiliary data structures recursion
has this sort of implicit
stack which is a data structure commonly
used in a lot of algorithms
and so having that sort of implicit
stack and
kind of self-managed looping construct
that's given to you
as a part of recursive calls you can
exploit that property
to really simplify your code and focus
on the problem you're solving
now the con for that is as you're
growing the amount of method invocations
in your computer memory you can actually
run out of memory
and we'll look at a lot of examples as
to why this is and we'll
we'll start to explore this this idea of
a stack overflow exception and
this is where we start to run out of the
pre-allocated buffer of memory
that we have for our program which can
actually cause
your program to crash
there are a lot of pros when it comes to
recursion when talking about
optimization reducing time complexity
and that's with this idea of memoization
and we'll look at some examples of
memoization and caching to help speed up
redundant calls and that's a beautiful
property
of recursion now the con
again just like any piece of code is
that if recursion is
overused you can get into this sort of
habit
where you start to develop really
complex code
if it's not well constructed and you
want to make sure that
and what will get a lot better at this
as we go through this this tutorial
is when you look at problems you want to
kind of ask yourself is this a good use
case
for recursion can i really break it down
into sub problems that make sense for
recursion
if you cannot then you may get into this
con where you have
unnecessarily complex code
now the final thing as i had mentioned
before is recursion works really well
for recursively defined data structures
json objects trees graphs
things that allow you to basically focus
on one
tiny unit of the data structure at a
time and it just so happens we'll look
at
a bunch of different examples as to why
this holds true
but this is just a small set of pros and
cons
things to consider when thinking about
using recursion
this brings us to a topic that i think
is often
overlooked when teaching recursion which
i think is one of the fundamental
concepts that you really need to grasp
to understand what people call quote
unquote magical
about recursion it's just magic with how
it works
and after we look at this example we'll
start to realize how logical
recursion is and why it's not
necessarily such a magical thing
let's imagine that you go to work one
day
and the first thing that you want to do
is check your email
and whilst checking your email you get
interrupted by your boss and your boss
says hey
i need you to go attend some meeting and
you have to actually deviate from your
task so you don't finish checking your
email you get interrupted
and before you can check your email now
you need to attend this meeting
now let's say your boss while walking to
this meeting your boss interrupts you
again
and he says hey our investors are
visiting
i would love for you to go to this board
meeting and impress them with all your
knowledge
and so again while walking to this
meeting you get
interrupted you have to go impress the
investors
right that's your next next task and so
before you can attend the meeting before
you can check your email
you need to impress these investors and
finally your boss he interrupts you
again
and he says hey you know i'm sorry but i
need you to go help jake with his code
his code is failing and we need to push
to production so
now you have to basically avoid the
investor meeting avoid the initial
meeting you can't check your email
until you help j code once you help him
this thing kind of gets popped off your
to-do list you know you go to the board
meeting
you attend this original meeting and
then finally
you can check your email
and you may be asking like why is this
ever at all relevant to
recursion and it just so happens that
this sort of idea
is exactly how the call stack works when
we're talking about invoking
methods within our programs
let's take a look at this simple program
here notice we have three method calls
and they're kind of chained
together the first one returns a string
but it has a dependency on b
b returns a string but it has a
dependency on c
and c just returns a string so nothing
fancy at all
now the call stack is going to be this
sort of abstraction
that our operating system leverages to
store
method invocations within our program
it allows us to understand what memory
addresses we return data to
and it stores local variable information
like what are the parameters that were
passed into me
so if we execute a the first thing that
goes on to the call stack is this sort
of
idea known as a stack frame
and it basically says hey i want to call
hello and i want to concatenate the
result of b
but in order for me to concatenate the
i need to actually now call b so that
pushes b
onto the call stack now i'm
in the same scenario where i want to
now return from b but i have a
dependency on c so now i call c
and put that on the call stack and
notice this is the same
sort of process that we looked at in the
previous analogy
i cannot return or pop these things off
the stack until i
kind of go in the order in which these
things were called so
i return friends right and now friends
replaces that c
invocation and so now this has been
fully evaluated
and so now since b is fully evaluated i
can return that value
to the b method invocation and now that
b stack frame gets popped off the stack
and it's only at this point that i have
now evaluated that entire chain of
method calls
so now i can return this string value
and get my expected output
now you may be asking like why still
why is this relevant to recursive
thinking
and let's look at an example let's look
at a call stack when we call these
recursive calls right this is just a a
program that calls itself and
it'll execute forever right so the first
time i invoke a
well now i need to invoke a but it calls
a again
and it just keeps happening right
there's no stopping condition and
finally
there's going to be this point this
point in time where i try and invoke a
again
and i i get a i get an error and that
error is a stack overflow
and this exception happens when we
exceed the pre-allocated buffer of
memory that our program has
right we basically have run out of
memory we've exceeded the stack
and our invocations have overflowed and
we can no longer handle it
and this is the whole thing with
recursion why we need a base case we
need to return a value
so just like we saw previously for
methods
that aren't recursive we notice that
frames
still grow and grow and grow and the
only way for those frames to shrink in
size
is for them to return some value for
them to stop
invoking methods and the same holds true
with recursion the only difference is
we have some sort of base case something
that says hey
this is the one thing that i want to
condition on to avoid us from further
recursing
i want to start off the first technical
component of this presentation looking
at
recursion with strings and this is going
to give us a really good idea of
manipulating
input parameters on the call stack
and the first problem i want to look at
is this idea of string reversal and so
what we do is we have an input string
like the simple engineer
and the idea is the output would be the
input in the reverse order
right and so the question is how do we
how do we build a really concise
recursive function that gives us
something like this
and as we look as we look at the
skeleton structure for this code we of
course are going to have some sort of
input right so the input's going to be
some string and the output is going to
be the reversed
version of that and so we always ask
kind of these two questions
the first is what is the base case and
this is really asking when can i no
longer continue
within my algorithm and the next line of
code is going to be all about
what's the smallest amount of work i can
contribute
so in this case it's going to be
basically between each invocation
what's the small unit that i can
actually
modify or manipulate to progress us a
little bit closer to the goal
so let's look at the first question the
first question is saying when can i no
longer continue
and i think i think when you think about
this sort of scenario there are two
schools of thought
and when i when i like to construct base
cases i typically think
if i were to just pass in a very small
input like what is the
smallest input that i could just pass in
to start
to this function where i would need to
basically
immediately return and there could be
two schools of thought with this
approach right
and the two schools of thought could be
well one letter
reversed is itself right and that could
be a really really good
base case for string reversal
but we want to be even lazier like what
is the
laziest like the least amount of work
that i could even consider
thinking about and that would be the
empty string the empty string reversed
is again just the empty string and so if
i passed in the empty string to this
function
then it would only make sense to get the
empty string back
and so if we if we modify the code and
we look at this
we just have a simple base case where we
evaluate if the input string
is the empty string then let's just
return the empty string
but now we need to consider how do i
even get to that point
what's the smallest amount of work that
i can contribute right and that's the
question that we're asking here
i need to do something that whittles
down the decision space
within each recursive call
and so we kind of asked this question
what's the smallest
unit that i can deal with in a string a
string is just a
a bunch of characters right and so maybe
i can modify a single character and this
is where we get to this question
let me pick a single character out of
this string
and maybe where i position it will allow
it to be
concatenated from the call stack in the
reverse order
and it turns out when we when we write
this code we get a recursive call where
we
we take that first character from the
input string and we concatenate it
after the recursive call
and you may be looking at this and you
say okay well the input parameter has
changed
and it's changed because we've actually
shrunken down the decision space we've
shrunk in that input string
because our entire goal is to get closer
to that base case
right and so we've taken everything
directly after the first character to
the end
and the idea is that if we do this
enough times we can shrink our search
space
on each invocation and get the goal
which is the reverse string so this
first piece is all
uh is all focused on shrinking the
problem space
and the second piece is reflecting
really the work that we're doing to
contribute
closer to the goal and i think it's
worthwhile to analyze
what is happening on the call stack so
let's say that we pass in
hello and we don't hit the base case on
line two we immediately go to line six
which is basically
the recursive invocation with the
shrunken down substring
and then we concatenate the h and just
as we had discussed with call stacks
we can't pop this off the call stack
until that recursive call
has also completed which adds an
additional stack frame to the call stack
and you notice again we don't hit the
base case and we shrink down that input
string
but we concatenate the first character
and we keep doing this
and it's nice because i don't need to
keep track of the h i don't need to keep
track of the e
it's all self-managed for me in the
stack frame on the call stack
and so i i invoke reverse string again
and now i get o
and now watch as this gets fairly
interesting because as i pass in o i get
to a point where my input string has
been whittled down to just the empty
string
and it just so happens that for this use
case this is the base case so i return
the empty string so that reverse string
gets evaluated to empty string
from this base case and i end up just
returning
the empty string plus o
and now this recursive call gets
evaluated and now i add
l and this just becomes ol right
and so now i can return this and this
gets popped off the call stack
and now you can see that i'm basically
returning these values
to the stack frame that preceded me and
popping things off the call stack
this function gets evaluated and adds e
so i return it and pop this off the call
stack
this function gets evaluated to o-l-l-e
so i return it it gets evaluated
and then this gets popped off the call
stack and as you can see
this is the goal right this is the
reverse string and it's the power of the
call stack the power of these recursive
calls
that allow us to return values back down
the stack
and this is a very good property that we
can exploit
when using recursion
let's look at palindromes palindromes
are these
unique words where we can basically
spell the same word forward and backward
let's look at this word the mechanical
way that we kind of analyze if a word is
a palindrome or not is we look at both
ends
and we basically say okay do these
letters match yes they do
so we shrink inward we say do these
letters match
yes they do so we shrink inward
and now this is just one character
and it proves that we've we've matched
successfully
so this indeed would be a palindrome
now let's look at a snippet of code to
see how we could think about something
like this recursively
now obviously we're going to have a
boolean function because it's either yes
it's a palindrome or no it's not
and we're going to evaluate some input
string
and of course the first thing we always
consider is what is this base case the
thing that stops us
from recursing now
think back to what i had said in the
previous example i always like to
consider my base cases what is the
smallest input
that i could just pass into this
function and it turns out very often not
very often for
string recursion you can typically
whittle down your search space and
evaluate the input length so if you
passed in a palindrome that was of size
zero then that's a palindrome right
because there's
there's nothing that proves it's not a
palindrome there are no characters to
compare against
and in the same vein if we pass in just
a single character
well a single character both forward and
backward is the same character
so that's also a palindrome so these are
really good use cases
or base cases to evaluate this
conditional
which is whether or not a string is a
palindrome
but let's continue we need to consider
the small amount of work
that we can do and in the animation that
we just looked at you notice that we had
two pointers
one on the left and one on the right and
we were comparing those strings
those characters we're saying they need
to be the same
if they're not the same at any point in
time then we've
violated the property of a palindrome
and if we violate the property of a
palindrome then we just go to this false
this is kind of this fallback base case
so at any point in the algorithm if the
characters don't match up at their
respective opposite indices
then we can terminate we return false
and the false gets propagated through
the call stack
and the initial caller function would
return
the false but if that's not the case
then we get to this interesting thing
where we call this recursive call and it
whittles down our
sub our substring so let's look at the
call stack to understand what's
happening
we pass in race car as an input string
and this of course is a palindrome you
can see race car forward and backwards
it's just race car
and the first thing we do is we evaluate
this this conditional this base case
is the length zero or one well it's
definitely not so we continue and now we
compare the first character and the last
character
for this input string and if they're
equal
then we just call ourselves again but we
shrink that input string
and since these since r and r are equal
we add another stack frame to the call
stack
and we've shrunken down our input string
we again look at the base case
we don't satisfy it so we compare the
first
and the last character and we notice in
this in this case
they're also equal so we call ourselves
again
right and we don't pop the stack frame
off the call stack because we still have
more work to do
and so we shrink down our input string
we still haven't satisfied the base case
and our characters
at the first and last position are still
the same so we do just a little bit more
work
and now we're at the last character and
we've already come to this conclusion
that
if the input length is 0 or 1 then we
just return true
so for this one particular sub problem
this one particular element
this is indeed a palindrome so what do
we do we say yes this was a palindrome
and we pop it off the call stack
and since we return true and all of
these other
conditionals have been satisfied then we
can just propagate through
uh the the true boolean down the call
stack
so we return true here and pop this off
we go to the next stack frame and return
true here and pop this off
and now we get to the final stack frame
which evaluates to true
and this gets popped off the stack
now i want to look at recursion
with numbers and the thing that you'll
start to realize as we go through these
sorts of problems
is that the same blueprint holds true
for all of them
and the first problem i want to look at
is this idea of converting decimal
base 10 values to binary which is a base
two
number format ones and zeros so the
question is how can we convert a number
like 25 into its binary counterpart
and it turns out there's a very
mechanical way of doing this so let's
take the number 233
and the formula here as we'll come to
find
is we can do a division by two and this
is basically doing the floor operator
so it gets us an integer instead of a
floating point value
and we get we get an output which is 116
and we have a remainder and that
remainder is one
and the mechanical process that we can
follow to convert decimal to binary is
we take the results of this
operation which is 116 and we divide
that by two
and we just keep evaluating and this is
remainder zero and then we take 58
and we divide that by two and this is 29
remainder zero
and we basically just keep taking the
resultant output and dividing it by two
and notice we're keeping track of the
remainders here
and the interesting property by doing
these operations gets us to a point
where we can take all of these
remainders so notice we've gotten to
this base case
which is zero and that kind of halts
this progression
so now we're done and if we take all of
these remainders
in the order that they were basically
pushed onto the stack
we can evaluate them and this is the the
resultant binary string
for 233 and the question is how can we
okay this this mechanical process you
know very formulaic
how can we convert it into some
recursive operation
let's take a look at some of this code
now notice we said the first thing is we
took 233 divided by 2
we got some output and the remainder was
1.
and so there are actually many ways
of of doing this problem and we're going
to keep it really simple so notice we're
dealing with strings
as the result outputs we're going to be
concatenating strings basically
and so what we consider here is we
we think about that base case right if i
hit zero
then there's no longer reason for me to
divide further
right i return my result
now if i have not hit zero yet it means
that i still have
more division to do and so the first
thing that we do
is we get that remainder so when we look
at 233 divided by 2
we want to store that remainder because
that represents one of the binary digits
that we care about
basically tells us that the value is
even or odd and this is the bind this is
the remainder
that will contribute to the result and
so that's why we store this
in the result and notice we just prepend
this to the result
and now what i do is i again just call
find binary and i shrink my problem
space by half
and i just propagate the result through
now let's let's actually look at the
call stack
by coding this and seeing what it looks
like i want to take the code that we
were just looking at
but look at it from the perspective of
the call stack
and understand how these stack frames
are building up over time
now there are many ways to code this
find binary function
and a lot of people do it returning an
integer and that's completely fine and
if you want to do it that way you can
actually follow along
with any modification of this and
analyze the call stack with me
so as we run in debug the call stack is
going to show up
down here so these are all the stack
frames that we can watch
grow and the variables on the current
stack frame will show up under here
in local and so as we dive into this
function
you notice that this is the first stack
frame for find binary
and in order for this to complete we
need to return some value
we haven't hit our base case yet so we
jump and do our work
and we just make another recursive call
so the first stack frame can't pop off
yet because we're going to invoke
ourselves again
and once we do that you notice that we
add another stack frame
and also notice that the input
parameters have changed we've shrunken
down our decision space
and we've appended the first digit to
our binary result
we haven't hit our base case yet and we
continue and again
we do a recursive operation and our
decision space keeps shrinking
and this is the same mechanical process
that we saw in the animation we divide
by 2
and log the remainder we divide by 2 and
log the remainder and we do this
until we hit some sort of base condition
right and as we shrink down our problem
space
notice we get to this point where the
decimal is one and that still
is not our base case so we go through
we get the result and this binary string
is looking pretty good and on the final
recursive call you notice the decimal is
now
zero and this is a really good case now
because now we can just return so we
come in here and we return this value
and this value comes and says okay find
binary for that invocation returned
this result and so now we're just saying
okay continue
and notice as i step through these stack
frames have grown
but now they should shrink off the call
stack so i step through
and notice they've all shrunken down so
all of them have returned
they've all returned to value and now
once i
step over here
we notice that the binary value has been
evaluated and you can come into this
debug console and look at it
and this is the resultant binary string
and so it's good to look at how the call
stack is working to understand
okay how many stack frames do we build
up to get to our result
and how do they unravel once we hit our
base case here
we've just straight up propagated the
result down through all of the stack
frames and all of them just return the
same thing
and we'll look at a lot of different
examples where all the stack frames kind
of work together
and they wait for the result to do a
little bit more work and so there's a
lot of different versions of this
the next problem that i want to look at
with numbers
is the sum of natural numbers and the
idea of this problem is
you take an input number like 10 and
then you sum all the values
up to 10. and what we do here
is we actually just add them all up and
we get some output and the output in
this case would be 55.
and the question is how can we build
some succinct function
that does this recursively
now let's look at a little snippet of
code and try to understand what's
happening
behind the scenes
so recursive summation again we take in
an input value
and the first question we need to ask is
what is the smallest input value
that i could pass in so if i pass in one
for example
the sum of one to one is just itself
one right and so that's a good that's a
good place
for the base case and again keep in mind
we are simplifying these functions
so you know edge cases we're not really
focused on that right now we're focused
on the core
goal which is building a succinct
function so if i pass in
one i would return one now
if i pass in a larger number like 55 i
still have a lot of work to do i need to
add up
all the preceding numbers up to 55 from
one
and so what i can do is i can take
whatever value i am
currently and i can add it
to myself again but subtracting one from
that number right so it shrinks me
closer to this base case
let's again look at some code and
understand how the call stack is working
with this sort of code so i've taken the
same code from the slide
and now we want to look at the call
stack and understand what's happening as
we make these recursive calls
the first thing that we'll look at is
the number five so we want to add all
values from one to five
let's put a break point here and debug
into the call stack
so as i dive into this operation we
first evaluate the base case
which hasn't been hit yet and so now
what i want to do is i want to take 5
and i want to add it to another
recursive call but that recursion
is shrinking down the input space again
and so as i dive in notice this input
number
change so i make the recursive call and
the input number has shrunken down to
four
and another stack frame has been added
to the call stack
and so we keep evaluating has the
conditional been hit no it has not
so i come in here and it shrinks down to
three
and i keep doing this and i come in here
i come in here
and now the input number is one
has the base case been hit yet yes it
has and so
if i dive into this you notice that we
return
one here and this 1 returns this value
to the stack frame right below it
and so notice that as i continue that
stack frame gets popped off and you can
see that the
invocation of this method returned 1
here and so now what i'm doing is i'm
taking two plus one
and i'm returning this value and this
value is going to continuously
unravel through these stack frames
so notice all of these get popped off
and here's the final invocation the
input number
is 10 here and as we continue
this is evaluating for recursive
summation of 10.
and so now again for 10 we get down to a
base case
and that base case is 1. and if we look
so i'll put a break point here and we
continue
we can see that we have the results of
and 55 and these get printed out
and so again this is just an example to
show as we're looking at the stack
frames
how a stack frame can return a value to
its previous stack frame
to finish the operation and that's the
key here
for recursion and we'll keep doing this
for a lot of the problems that we look
at to get familiarized
with how the call stack is working and
how the stack frames grow
i want to talk about divide and conquer
algorithms
which are really great demonstrations of
recursion
and the blueprint that we think about
for divide and conquer holds through so
we you know still divide a large problem
into several small problems
but divide and conquer is all about we
divide them into subproblems we
independently solve them and then we
actually merge the results to solve some
holistic
problem right we merge them together and
say hey this is the solution
and they are typically recursive and
let's look at the first one
which is binary search and the entire
purpose of binary search is we look at a
sorted list of numbers and the key
point here is they're sorted
and let's call this array a and the
first thing that we say is we say all
right i'm going to start with the left
and right index so the far
left index is 0 and the far right index
is the length
of the array minus 1. and the whole
purpose of binary search is to find a
value we want to find a value in this
array
so we know that 0 is less than the
length of the array so we
have not hit our base case and we
calculate the midpoint
so the midpoint is the left and right
index added together
and divided by 2. and so we check we say
okay is that midpoint
the answer that we're looking for so
that's another sort of base case
have we hit or found the number 10 here
and the answer is no so we ask one of
two questions the first question that we
ask
is is the number that we're looking for
on the left half of the array
or is the number that we're looking for
on the right half of the array
and remember we we just found the
midpoint so we're considering
everything to the left of the midpoint
and everything to the right of the
midpoint
because the input data is sorted now
if it's on the left half which is what
we're looking at here
then we completely discard the right
half
and notice the way that we do that is we
change the bounds of the problem
so the left half stays the same so our
starting point on the left stays the
same
but we only consider up to the midpoint
minus one
and so that is our ability to shrink our
decision space and completely discard
the right half
in each recursion or each recursive
invocation
now if we get to this other evaluation
this is basically saying the value we're
looking for is on the right
half and what this allows us to do is we
only consider our starting point to be
the midpoint plus one all the way to the
end so we completely discard the left
half
for the rest of this problem and this
indeed is also a recursive call
so look at the first stack frame in the
call stack to the right
we start with zero our upper bound index
for
the right variable is nine and the
number we're searching for is 10.
so here's our midpoint this is 3 and we
ask this question
is this the value that we're looking for
is this 10 and the answer is
no it's not
so what we can do is we can discard the
entire left half of the search space
because
10 is greater than the midpoint
and it turns out we add another stack
frame to the call stack and notice how
the parameters have changed
now for the left the starting bound
which is the left
is 5 which is the index where 4 is
and the upper bound is 9 which is the
original length of the array that we're
working with
and again we calculate the midpoint the
midpoint on this
subarray is nine and we say is ten
greater than nine or less than nine
and of course we know ten is greater
than nine and so what we can do is
completely discard
the left half of that subarray and
continue
and we add another stack frame and the
stack frame
the start bound is eight and the upper
bound is nine
and we again recalculate the midpoint
and the midpoint at this point actually
turns out on line seven we've hit this
base case
the base case here is that we've found
the number that we're looking for and
this is the solution and so what we can
do
is just return this value
but we're not done yet because we need
to still consider the call stack
and so this value is 10 and so what we
do from this stack frame is we return
10 and in this case we're returning the
index that 10 is at
so 10 is at the eighth index of the
array and this gets
popped off the stack and now this binary
search
invocation has been completed and it
gets eight so it just returns
eight and this gets popped off the stack
and now finally we return eight and
we're complete
and the final stack frame gets popped
off the stack
and that's how binary search works let's
look at fibonacci a classical
mathematical and computer science
problem that often demonstrates
the power of recursion and we're going
to be looking at the non-optimized
version here and we'll we'll add some
optimizations at the end
and let's look at the mathematical
expression first we're basically saying
that
for some input in
at the index n is going to be made up of
the
sum of the two values at the two indices
that precede it
let's look at the wikipedia page for
fibonacci
and this is the sequence the fibonacci
sequence
and if we take one of these numbers like
it's the sum of the two numbers that
precede it so 34 and 21
and if we look at 34 it's the sum of 21
and 13 and if we look at 13 it's the sum
of 8 and 5
etc and this this formula holds true for
all values of 1 to infinity
and so this is the fibonacci sequence so
if we look at this expression again
now we have these base cases in pink and
it basically says
that for the values of at index 0
and 1 the base cases are 0 and 1
respectively and we can just return
at that point so that would be where we
stop the recursion
and the piece of yellow is just saying
that this this holds true for all values
of one to infinity
so let's let's kind of look at this
and understand why it differs from the
previous
now we're dividing and conquering right
we're dividing this problem we have
fib of n minus one that needs to happen
we add it to fib of
n minus two and these are two recursive
calls
and as we think back how the call stack
works we know that the recursion on the
left needs to complete
before we even considering uh consider
starting
the recursive call on the right so fib
of n
minus one could have a ton of different
calls that need to complete
before we even do the plus operator to
fib of n minus two
so let's look at how this would animate
so we want to find the fibonacci of five
and like i had said we do not evaluate
the right hand side of the expression
yet because we need to
satisfy that first recursive call first
so this gets us
f fib of 5 minus 1 which is 4.
and this gets us 4 minus 1 which is 3.
and this process continues f of 2.
and remember our base case f of 1 is
just 1 so we would return from here
and now 2 can evaluate the right hand
side of its recursive operation
remember we're calling the same function
over and over again so now we've hit a
base case
we've evaluated the left hand side which
is fib of n
minus 2 or fib of n minus one and now we
can do fib of n minus two
for this value which is f of zero this
again is a base case
so we can return from here now
the sum of these two values return and
get passed up to f of three
and now f of three can evaluate its
recursive call on the right-hand side of
that plus operator
and again we do f of one that's a base
case so we just return it
right now this these f of two f of one
get added together to return from f of 3
and this gets passed to f
4 and now f 4 can evaluate the right
hand side of its expression
which is f of n minus 2. so here we get
f 2 and again this recursive property
holds true
this is a base case we return it we
evaluate the right hand side
this is a base case we return it and now
this gets propagated back up to f
4 and these values get propagated back
up to f of 5.
and it's from here now this is the very
first
you know call of the function we can now
evaluate the right hand side of that
plus operator
and again we get down to f of three we
get down
to f of two and then this is f of one
and this is a base case so we return it
and this is f of zero this is a base
case we return it and notice like we're
doing the same thing over and over again
this gets returned
now we go to the right hand side this
gets returned
this gets passed up and now we can add
these two values
and that's how we find the fibonacci
now we'll look at optimizations for this
later but i just want to point out one
thing like as we
evaluate this notice we have f of 3 here
we have f of 3 here this is redundant
right all of the nodes below f 3 are the
exact
same and so it seems extremely wasteful
that we're recalculating these values
and so as we'll come to realize
there are optimizations that we can
consider to avoid recalculating
something that we've already done the
work for
so if you look we have f of 2 f of 2 and
f of 2.
and this is three nodes and you can
imagine for really large numbers it
turns out for fibonacci
you know most modern day computers
cannot run
fibonacci for this function at a very
high
input and that's because the the
recursive calls are
so intensive so we have to look at some
optimization techniques
known as memoization merge sort
is this poster child of
divide and conquer when explaining this
in a lot of computer science classes
and the idea is that we take in a bunch
of unsorted
values like the following and the
the idea is that we divide this array in
such a way
that we keep dividing and then we merge
up the sorted results
to sort this array in ascending order
and it kind of looks like this so we
split the array in half and we say all
right i'm going to focus on
the left-hand side and remember before i
even do the
hand side i need to finish the left hand
side first right that's the order in
which recursion is going to operate here
and this process just holds through so
this is the left-hand array and what do
i do i split this in half
and now i decompose this into two parts
but again i first have to focus on this
half
and then i can focus on this half so i
look at
you know i split these and i look at
four and one
and the base case here is that you can't
really sort just one value
and so i can stop splitting when i hit
just one value and i compare these two
and i merge and sort them together just
by a simple comparison operator
now i can look at the right half side
and i basically split
these so i have one integer here
and i take two and zero and two and zero
get split even further and again i'm
down to this case where i just have
digits and so zero and two get compared
they get merged up
now three has a linear time comparison
against zero and two
and these get merged together and now we
take
one and four zero two and three these
get merged together
and now i've solved the left half of
this array
but remember now i need to do the right
half we're evaluating in the order that
recursion
would consider this so when we split
this i get the right half of the array
and i do the same thing on this side
so i take this array i split it i get
negative one
and seven this gets split
i compare them and it just so happens
they were already in sorted order
so these get put back in the same spot
now i take the right half of the array
right and i split this even further
and so when this gets split i have 10 9
and 20 gets split
9 and 20 are individual digits and when
i compare them they are already in
sorted order
and then i compare all the digits here
and they get merged back in sorted order
and then again finally i compare these
digits and they get merged back in
sorted order
and this brings us to the final merge
remember divide and conquer is all about
dividing your problem into sub problems
and then merging the results together
so what we've done is we've just
recursively merged all the results
together from the recursive sub calls
and this is the final merge and
just to emphasize how this comparison
works to ensure that these things get
put back
in sorted order we do a linear
comparison
and what that means is we basically have
two pointers starting at the left-hand
side and we say all right
which number is smaller and we know
negative one is smaller so we put this
in its spot and increment the pointer
and then we compare these two values
well 0 is smaller here so we put that in
spot and increment the pointer
and we keep doing this as we compare
values
and notice here we've actually run out
of values
in the left-hand array and since we
already know the right-hand array is
sorted we just place these back
in the positions they belong and as we
look at the resultant array
we notice that merge sort has sorted the
input
completely and so this right here
is the sorted solution
and now the question is how do we build
something like this how do we devise
a recursive algorithm that could
construct a sorting
you know solution to a problem like this
we're going to look at some code to do
that
so we have a blank slate here and we
want to consider how
merge sort would work to satisfy the
properties that we looked at
now the first thing i want to do is
build the recursive call
and so remember merge sort takes in an
array and it sorts it and we're going to
do this in place so i'm going to build a
function
that's public and static
and it's just going to be void so we're
going to modify the original
input array and what i'm going to take
in this is going to be called
merge sort and it's going to take in
just a one dimensional
integer array and we'll call it data and
it'll have a start
and an end which will represent the
indices that we're working with
now for merge sort this is going to be a
recursive call we need to consider the
base cases
remember we work from the start to the
end
and if those values overlap then we've
hit our base case
so we asked this question if start is
less than end then we can continue doing
work
but if the start passes whatever the end
pointer is
then there's no more work to continue
we've already sorted the data
and so remember we're all about taking
the array and splitting it in two halves
we want to divide the problem into two
halves and solve them
independently and so the first thing
that we can do is we can calculate the
midpoint
and so what we do is we say int mid is
going to be basically
whatever the start index is of the array
plus the
end index and we divide that by two
and that's going to be the midpoint that
we're working with
and what do we want to do here well what
we want to do is we want to divide the
array
in two parts and so it would make sense
for us to just call merge sort we're
dealing with the same data array
but our bounds are what has changed
and so the start is again for the first
half
gonna start at the same position but the
end
is going to end at the midpoint
and that's going to be the left sub half
now if we think about the right sub half
the start is going to change right the
start is going to be whatever the
midpoint is plus one
all the way to the end and this is how
we can consider
splitting this array into two different
sub halves
but the question is how do we how do we
merge this data right what we're doing
is we're just continuously
dividing and dividing and dividing
but i want to be able to merge the data
in sorted format
so let's build a function called merge
and what merge is going to do it's going
to take the original data array
and it's going to start taking the start
the midpoint
and the ending index and remember that
last animation that we just looked at
does this kind of linear time comparison
to replace the values in the correct
spot
when it's looking at the two sorted
subarrays
so i build a function here it's going to
be public
static void and i'm just going to call
this merge
and again it's going to take in an
integer array called data
a starting point a midpoint and an
endpoint
and now remember we we basically need to
merge these values but i don't want to
modify the input array yet
so i'm going to build a temporary array
so it would make sense to build a
temporary array
to avoid modifying
can't type to avoid modifying the
original contents
and so in order for me to do that i can
just build a simple
temp array here and it'll be a new int
array
and the size is just going to be
dependent on the indices
right so i have n minus start plus one
so this is going to build me a
pre-allocated
buffer of memory to hold all the data
for the subarrays that i'm dealing with
from the start
and end index
and now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to copy the values
so i want to i don't want to lose a
reference to the start or
midpoint so i'm going to say in i equals
start
we'll say j is equal to mid plus one
and k is equal to zero and k is going to
be this kind of track or variable
that we use to keep track of the values
that we put into this temporary
so let's continue now recall back when
we were merging
the data together in that final sub call
that's a good way to
kind of realize how this is working so
we're basically doing a linear time
comparison
at the values in the left array and the
pointer
on the right array and we're saying
which one is smaller whichever one is
smaller
is going to be placed first in this
temporary
and so i'm basically saying while i
is less than or equal to mid which is
going to be
the left sub array and we want to say
well j
is less than or equal to the end
then we can continue and what is this
saying
what this is saying is while both
of the subarrays have values then try
and merge them in sorted order
right and that's what we want to do so
we're starting with i
which is the left sub array up to the
midpoint
and then j which starts from the
midpoint to the end
is going to be the right sub array and
we just want to compare these values
and so we ask a question we say all
right well if data sub i
is less than or equal to data sub j
then we know what we know that the value
in the left subarray is less than
whatever the value is in the right sub
array
so what we can do is we can say all
right in this temporary buffer
i'm going to put in at the index k
data sub i so the smaller value gets put
next in the temporary and now what i
want to do is i want to increment i
since i've already placed it in the
array and i want to increment k
so i don't override this value
now if this condition doesn't hold true
then what i can say is well okay so
that would imply the opposite so i would
just say temp of k
is going to equal data sub
j
and then what we would do is we would
say k plus plus
and j plus plus and you can also get
fancy you can come in here and do
something like k plus plus here
and you can do something like j plus
plus here it's both
it's going to be the same thing so if
you want to simplify your code that way
you can do the post increment operator
to reduce the amount of code
and this handles basically the
comparison
between the subarrays but remember the
conditional here the conditional says
we only do this while both values
have values to compare against in the
example that we looked at we actually
ran out of data in the left subarray and
we just had to
just blindly place all the data in the
right subarray
into the original array and so we need
to satisfy that case here
in order to do that we can just say
while i is less than or equal to the
midpoint
so while there's basically data to
traverse still
we're just going to place it into the
position of the temp array
where it belongs this would be data sub
i
and again we would do k plus plus
and i plus plus and that handles
exhausting
the left sub array if the right sub
array has run out of values
so we say add the rest
of the values from the left subarray
into the result
now on the opposite side if the left
subarray
has run out of values but we still have
data in the right sub array
then we just need to have the reverse
conditional we say while j is less than
or equal to end
then we're just going to say temp sub k
is equal to data sub j
and then again we just increment k
and we increment j
and this is the same thing we're adding
the rest of the values
from the right subarray into the result
you may ask are we done yet and we're
almost done
but we need to remember we built this
temp array and this is void
and so we haven't really done any work
yet and so the question we need to ask
is how do we modify the original data
array
in memory now we don't want to modify
the entire array we
only want to modify the subsection that
we're dealing with right now
in whatever recursive call that we're in
and so this brings us to
the copy phase how do we copy this data
over from temp into the right positions
of the data which is the original data
and it turns out we can just have a
simple for loop where we say i is equal
to start
and while i is less than end right so
we're only taking the subsection that
we're dealing with
so from start to end right which could
be any
any bounds at any point of the recursion
so while i
is equal to start and i is less than or
equal to end
we're just going to increment i and in
each iteration we're going to
load up the original data array at the
index i
to be equal to whatever's in the temp
array
at the value of i minus start
so if the data array that we're dealing
with if the start is 12
then what we would do is we would say
all right well i equals 12 so 12
minus star is zero so we're going to
load data sub 12
with whatever's at temp sub zero and
this is the copy phase this is how we
actually
override values at each subarray
let's actually run some input here
i'm going to have a new input array
we'll say
you know data equals new int and we'll
just load it with some values we'll say
negative 5
you know 20 10 3 2
0. and what i want to do is i want to
sort this
so i'm going to call merge sort
and i'm going to give it the data array
the start is going to be the 0th index
and the end is going to be the length
minus 1.
and so this should sort the array in
place and so what i can do
is i can put a breakpoint
to look at the array once it's been
sorted and then we'll look at the call
stack to see what actually is happening
behind the scenes
so i'm going to debug and we'll notice i
get here
and merge sort has completed and
what i can do is i can look at this
stack frame and look at the data
and you notice that we have in the 0th
index negative 5
0 2 3 10 and 20.
and so this is the output in sorted
order
but this doesn't really do us any good
unless we understand what's happening
at the level of the call stack so let's
take a look at that
if i put a breakpoint in the merge sort
function
let's kind of look and see what's
happening
if i dive in here the first stack frame
gets added to the call stack for merge
sort
and i basically ask is start less than
end
and the answer is no we still have work
to do
and so when i go in here i calculate the
midpoint and i say i want to divide this
array into two sub halves
and the midpoint here is two and so what
i do is i say all right i'm going to
divide
everything from zero to two into its own
set of sub arrays
and then i'll handle the right half and
remember i can't even go to the right
half until the left half has completed
so i dive into this
and now i'm looking at everything from
zero to two
and i have to break this up even further
and so now i'm at this position where
the midpoint is one
and again i grow the call stack and i'm
still only on the left hand side
and i calculate the midpoint again and i
go again
and now we don't satisfy this right
because 0 and 0 are
equal and so we actually pop this off
the call stack
and now we return to the next recursive
call and the next recursive call says
okay now i want to handle the right hand
side of this
right and when i dive into this i grow
the call stack again
and again we pop off right we don't
satisfy this base case and we kind of
just continue this operation
and so now i've reached the basically
the base case on the far
left hand side of the first left sub
half of this array
and what it's asking me to do is it's
asking me to now merge these values in
sorted order
so if i dive in here and we look at the
merge let's analyze
the start the mid and the end
remember i'm only dealing with basically
two values here
and so if i go in here we have a temp
array and it's only of size two
and that's because my base case here for
merge sort is only really comparing two
values
and so we go in here and we say all
right which one's smaller
the left value or the right value and i
come in here and i say okay well here
the left value is smaller so i load up k
i load up temp
and i put in negative five and then i
have another while loop
and remember because i ran out of values
to compare in the left sub-array
i need to basically take all the values
in the right sub-array and put them
in the positions they belong so i come
down here and i load up the values
increment the counters and now we're
done
because we've hit this base case
so now i have this sorted subarray
negative 5 and 20.
and what do i need to do i need to put
these in the original spot
right and if we look at these values i
have you know i j and k
what does that mean well it means that
from the position that i'm dealing with
in the original array i need to override
those values
so that's what this replacement is going
to do so i come in here i replace value
i replace value 2 and now i'm done
and that is the process that we go
through for
a single iteration of merge sort and
this process will basically continue
as we are dealing with bigger and bigger
sub arrays as we recurse
back from the bottom up right and now
we're merging again
and notice like since we did the left
sub half which was just two values
now we're dealing with the right sub
half right
and now we have three values and it's
the right
sub half of another sub problem and so
we just continue
comparing and going up and going up now
we won't go through
every stack frame in this call there are
quite a few
as we saw in the animation but i
encourage you to rewatch that animation
because that is the order that the call
stack will be evaluated
and that's the order in which things
will recurse back up
from the sub-problems to get merged into
some overall solution
and that's one of the key components of
divide and conquer
link lists are really common data
structures used
to store data that is not necessarily
contiguously stored in memory
and it turns out you can do a lot of
cool recursion on these sorts of things
we're going to look at linked list
reversal and we'll look at an animation
to walk through this code now the idea
is that we have
some sort of linked list let's say we
have values
in sorted order like this and we'll just
have a bunch of pointers
and the idea is that the head node
changes from one
pointing to two pointing to three four
five instead we want
six to point toward five five to point
toward four
and so on and when we look
at this code this reversal code we ask
this question
all right if the head node is null right
if we pass in a null value
or the next value from the head is null
then we just return the head and this
kind of brings us back to that idea of
considering base cases
what's the smallest thing i could pass
in if i passed in
null then i can just return null and
that would be a reversed list
right and in the same vein if i passed
in just a single node
where there was no next node then i
could just return head again
and those are good base cases for this
solution
but the question is how do i even start
the reversal what's the unit of work i
need to do and that's what we're going
to look at
so we start with one the head node that
we pass in on the first iteration
is one and we don't hit the base case
and so on line three we see that we call
reverse list head.next
and that immediately pushes us to the
next node
and we have one stack frame on the call
stack
now we're looking at two and this this
is not null either and it also
doesn't have a pointer pointing to null
and so we execute line three again
at another stack frame on the call stack
and that gets us to three
and this process continues all the way
until we get to six
and when six gets passed in as a
parameter we say is it null and the
answer is no but the next value is null
and so what do we return what we do is
we return
head which is just 6 and 6 gets returned
as the node to the previous value
so this is the base case and we return
this
to 5. and so now p has been evaluated to
the number six
and what we're saying since since the
number five is the current head node
we're saying
five dot next dot next equals five
and it turns out that what that means is
we're basically just saying okay well
what i want you to do is take six and
have it point back to five
because head.next is six and head.next
which is six dot next is going to be
pointing to five
and if that doesn't make sense i
encourage you to really slow down and
read this code
and think five is the head node and we
wanna say the next pointer's
next position just points back to our
self
now the problem here is that five is is
also pointing to six
and if we were to trace this this would
this would be a cyclic dependency and
this would never end right
and so what we can do is we can just say
fives.next
can point to nothing right this is null
and so that gets dropped off
and what we return is we return six
because we want
six to be the new head and so six will
just get propagated down the call stack
to the original caller to be the new
head node and that's why we return
p here and so now we return and we get
to 4.
and when we look at 4 we know that p
is six and what we're asking here is
we're saying
four's next node is five and i want five
to point to four
and so again we do the same thing we
take five it points to four and to avoid
the cyclic dependency we drop this
pointer here
this connection and what do we return
well we return
six because again six gets propagated
through and six is always going to be p
in this case and so now i return
and i know six is p but head.next is
four
and so i want four to point to three so
i say head.next.next
equals three so i draw a pointer
and again i drop the cyclic dependency
and i get rid of this connection
and now i return p is still 6
i return to 2 and i say
2's next value which is 3 i want
three.next to point to two
so we do this i drop the pointer and i
return
and then finally we do this again i drop
the pointer
and now we're done so
let's let's take the opportunity to look
at the call stack
and really understand how this is
working in a little bit more detail
in order to save some time i've written
some code
the first piece of code i want to look
at is this idea of a node
now this node is just an abstraction
that holds a value
and a pointer to the next node and so
this is
the easiest way to build a singly link
list
now i also made a method called print
link list and this will just print all
the values
and this is a verification that we can
use to ensure
that we've reversed the link list
correctly
and the final thing i want to look at is
the actual code so this is the same code
that was on the slide and i want to look
at the call stack as we debug through
this
so i have a singly linked list here one
two
three four five just as we looked at and
they're all linked together
and what we want to do is we want to
actually see how the reversal is working
so if i run and debug this
we're going to look at the call stack
so the first thing i hit is this call
and you'll notice in the stack frame as
i dive into this function this is the
initial
stack frame that gets put onto the call
stack and i ask myself
is the node that i'm looking at which is
1 is it null
the answer is no is the next value null
the answer is no
it's two right we can see that here
so i continue through and i just call
reverse list again
which is a recursive call and as i dive
into this
i add another stack frame to the call
stack and now you see my values 2
and my next node is still not null so i
continue through
and i add another recursive call which
adds another stack to the stack frame
to the call stack and i continue and
this process
is going to keep continuing
now notice here the value is 5
but my next value is actually null and
that satisfies this base case here
so if we continue you notice i just
return
null here and this stops the recursion
so notice the stack frame should get
popped off
so as i continue through that stack
frame gets removed
and now i'm looking at four and it
actually shows me what the result of
this
recursive call was for p so as i step
over
we can look at p and see that p is just
5.
and so i'm basically saying the
node.next
so let's evaluate that so node.next
has a value of five and i'm basically
saying i want five to point
so i want five dot next to point to
whatever my current value is which is
four right
so we know node.val
is four so i'm changing the pointers
here so as i step over
now i have four
pointing to null
as i execute this so we step over one
more so as i look at
node.val dot node.next
this should be null which it is
and now the value p which was five
should be pointing to four now
so p dot next dot val
is four right and so the whole
idea here is that now we return the very
last node again
and we pop this off the call stack
and the node that we're looking at at
this point
is three and
right now three is pointing to four
right so if we look at node.val which is
three
we can say node.next.val and this is
four
but this is wrong right because we want
four to be pointing to three not three
pointing to four
and so that's what this line is doing
i'm saying i want four
to point back to three and so i do that
and then i drop the connection
and so now if i evaluate this
and we look at p we can actually see the
progress that we've made
five points to four and four points to
three
okay so we're not done yet but we're
making progress
and as we return from here we pop off
the call stack
and we just keep doing this process we
return we pop off the call stack
we come up here we return and we pop up
the call stack
and now we're back to the original call
and remember how we propagated the very
last value
throughout all these calls so
as we look at the reversed value reverse
dot val
it's five and this is our new head node
which was the goal of this problem
and so if we come and we look at
reversed we say okay
we have five the next value is four the
next value there is three the next value
there is two
and the next value there is one and then
we're complete
and so this is how the call stack works
for a linked list
reversal a really fun problem to
consider with linked lists is how do you
merge
two sorted link lists recursively we're
going to look at
how the call stack works for this let's
analyze this small snippet of code and
see if we can conceptualize what's
happening on the call stack
we take in two head nodes one
is a list of values and the other is a
singly linked list of values as well
and we asked this question the first
question is what's the smallest input i
could pass in and that's a good
consideration for our base case
the same formula that we've been
applying if i pass in
a head node for a that's null then i can
just return
b because b
would be merged with null which would
just be itself
and in the same vein if b is null and i
merge that with a
then i can just return a and if they're
both null
then null merged with null is also just
the null
value so this holds true
and that's the base case but let's
consider the other side of things
and this is kind of a similar comparison
that we saw with merge sort
right now we're considering okay first
of all
[Music]
base case but second of all what's the
unit of work that we need to do the
recursion
and i think it'll help if we look at two
lists
so we have two sorted lists of values
and we want to go through this recursive
call
and the first thing that we do is we add
a stack frame to the call stack
and it basically says the head nodes
that i have are one
and four so neither of them are null
and what i want to do is i want to say
all right which which value is smaller
the value in the first node or the value
in the second node a or b
a's dot data is one and b's bs.data is
four so that first conditional
is the one that will be recursed upon
and i basically say
one dot next is going to be pointing to
sorted sorted merge
and node a is going to be incremented by
one value
so i add another stack frame to the call
stack
and so now i pass in eight and now eight
is getting compared with four and we
still haven't hit our base case right
and so i look at the else statement and
i compare 8 and 4 and 4 is obviously
smaller
and so this is going to be the next node
that i consider
and i just continue this process so now
8 and 11 gets compared
and since 8 is smaller then i pass in 22
and i add another stack frame and now 22
and 11 get compared
and since 11 is smaller i pass in the
node right after 11
and these get compared and notice
in the calls the recursion needs to
complete but i'm actually setting these
results
as the next value and so as we compare
22 and 16
16 is smaller so i pass in 20.
and now 20 is smaller but it's
interesting because there is no node
after 20.
and so now i'm at this point where i
have null
and now we we consider the base case if
we have a null value which is b in this
case then i just return
a and if i return a then i'm just
returning the
reference to the node of 22.
so here's the base case and what i can
do is i can
just simply return 22 here and this gets
popped off the call stack
and this is where the unraveling starts
to begin
so when i return 22 here
i actually change 20s dot next pointer
right because i'm saying
20.next is equal the result of sorted
merge
and since sorted merge return 22 i can
now modify this pointer
and from here i return a and when i
return a i'm just returning 20
and this gets popped off the call stack
and now you know we're looking at 16 and
we're saying what should 16's next
pointer be
well 16 should point to 20 but it
already is pointing to 20 so we don't
really need to do anything
and so i return from here 16 and this
gets popped off the call stack
and again in the same in the same case
11 is already pointing to 16
so we don't need to modify anything but
we return 11 from here and this gets
popped off the call stack
and now we have this question 8 was
pointing to 22 but since we returned
11 we can now say that 8 is going to
point to 11
and that means we modify the pointer
which we've done
right and now we return 8
from this stack frame the smaller value
and this gets popped off the call stack
now we compare 8 and 4. 4 was pointing
to 11 but since 8 got returned from the
recursive call
then we take 4 and we point it to 8.
now we return the smaller value from the
stack frame
and what do we do here well what happens
here
is we pop this off the call stack and 4
is the smaller value
and so now what we want is we want 1 to
point to the 4 node
and this is our final stack frame
and from here we just return 1 which is
the head node
which is the smallest value from the two
sorted lists
and from here this gets popped off the
stack frame
and if we follow these edges or these
pointers
we notice 1 goes to 4 goes to 8 goes to
to 16 to 20 to 22 to 40. and this ends
up being our sorted list
and even for this we can take a second
to
look at the code and understand the call
stack
all right so i've gone ahead and i've
actually built
a couple link lists so we have one here
so 1 5 13 14 and 550 and we have another
completely independent link list 215 130
200 and 350 and the idea here is how do
we take these
and merge them in their sorted order
and so we take the same code that we
were just looking at
but now we want to analyze it from the
call stacks perspective
and so i'm going to come over here and
i'm going to put a break point on the
initial call
and we're going to debug into this
function
so as i dive into this function you'll
notice the call stack grows
and now we have two lists this would be
a and b from the example so we have one
and two and this corresponds to the two
initial nodes that we have here
two and one
and what we're doing is we're checking
if you know the first list
is null then we return the second list
and if the second list is null we return
the first list
this of course does not hold true yet so
we continue and compare the values
since one is less than two we jump in
here and we
do another recursive call and notice
that we pass in
the next value that one was pointing to
but two stays the same
and we continue this comparison now
since 5 is greater than 2 we go to the
second conditional
and we do a recursive call and notice
these stack frames are just growing
they're just growing and this stack
frame is dependent on the result of this
stack frame
and as i continue through and do these
comparisons i have another stack frame
and each subsequent stack frame has a
dependency
on the results of whichever one is above
it
and so we keep doing this and we do this
until we hit one of these base cases
so i continue through and now i've hit a
base case
the value that we have is list one which
is 550
and i'm just going to return this and
when i return it
what happens well it's the result of
this function so i say l2.next is 550
and when that gets evaluated i just
return here and you notice that these
stack frames will start shrinking now
because we've hit a base case
and so as i continue through and i'm
returning these values
you notice that our call stack is
shrinking in size
and we're basically reassigning the
pointers to the next node
and it shrinks and shrinks and shrinks
and now finally we get to a point where
the sorted operation is complete and so
if we look at sorted merge if we look at
this value
we notice that the first value is one
the next value is 2
5 13 and it's now
in sorted order so we've taken two
sorted lists and merged them
in ascending order which is the expected
output
and this is just an example of taking
two linked lists and showing how the
merge operation works
on the call stack this brings me to
one of my favorite topics which is trees
and trees are one of the really
fantastic data
structures that work really well with
recursion and the first question we're
going to look at is
inserting a value into a binary search
tree
now a tree for especially a binary
search tree
is going to be a series of nodes and
we're going to basically start from the
top
down we're going to have a bunch of
connections and the number of children
at most that we can have from a single
node is two
and the least amount of nodes you can
have is zero and so what we're going to
do is we're going to add a bunch of
numbers here
and analyze the properties of this tree
notice that everything to the left of
the root node 100
is less than 100 and everything to the
right is greater than 100.
now this property it turns out holds
true recursively
so if we look at 80 everything to the
left is less than 80
everything to the right is greater than
80.
but it's interesting because everything
to the right is greater than 80
but also still less than 100
and so if you look the largest value on
the subtree of 80
on the right subtree is 95 and 95 is
still less than 100
and so if you're not familiar with the
properties of binary search trees i
encourage you
to just do a quick quick look and look
at the rules for that but this is pretty
much
the entire rule set for a binary search
tree
and we're faced with this task and the
task is to add this
node and the node is 108.
and if we look at this value we
basically say okay i'm going to start at
the top of this tree and i'm going to
figure out where can i place 108 and i
compare i say is 108
greater than 100 or less than 100 or
equal to 100.
and i say it's greater than so i go to
the right
and i ask is 108 greater than 120
or less than less than or equal to 120
and we see it's less than so i go to the
left sub half
and i ask the same question is 108
greater than 110 or less than 110 and i
see it's less than
and so now i go down here and i draw a
connection
and this is the point where 108 belongs
and here you can see it's it's still
satisfies the rule set right
108 is greater than 100 so it satisfies
that property it's less than 120
it's less than 110 so this is the valid
position for 108.
and so let's look at the code turns out
the code for this is
extremely simple
and like i had said before we consider
the base case
what's the smallest thing i can pass in
well what if there is no root
right what if this is the first value
that we're inserting into the tree
well if that's the case then what i do
is i just create a new node
i set the data and i return that value
right and it turns out that's a fairly
good base case
now if we consider the other case now we
need to start thinking about
okay well what if i need to do some
comparisons and this is where i start
comparing the data so let's look
at what's happening the first question
says if i hit null
i've recursed to my end goal according
to the search tree properties of the
binary search tree
now remember binary search tree node
insertions will always happen
at the leaf level so they always happen
at the end so if you've done all your
comparisons until the very end
then you've hit a valid position to
insert the data
right and that valid position would be
when you have no more comparisons to do
which is implied by the head node being
null
now the next conditional i look at is
basically saying okay i'm at a node
and i want to compare it to my current
node so remember when we were comparing
108 to 100
i asked this question i say is the node
i want to insert greater
or less than this value if it's greater
then i say head dot write equals
and then i just make another recursive
call and i progress to either the left
or right half of the subtree
the other side is just the opposite so
if i'm less than the current node then i
want to go down
the left hand side of the subtree
now this final piece right here is once
i've done all this work i've done all
the insertions
i just want to return the original root
node
and that original roon node just says
basically here's the tree that you
started with
let's look at the call stack during this
insertion process
i call insert node and i'm comparing 100
and 108
and i know 108 is greater than 100 so i
recurse down
the right hand side now when i get to
this point i add another stack frame and
i'm comparing 120 and 108
and i know 108 is now less than this so
i recurse down the left-hand side
now here i'm comparing 108 110
add another stack frame i compare these
values
and because it's less than i go to the
left hand side
and this is interesting because now my
value that i compare against is null
and remember when we look at the code
here null is just the base case
this is what we consider when we insert
a node
and so i just create that 108 node and i
return it
right and so here is where i would say
okay new node
head data equals 108 and i would return
this node
and so from this stack frame i would
actually return
the 108 node and pop this off the stack
and what i would do here because i was
saying 110 dot left
equals whatever that value was now i can
draw a connection to 108
and just start returning those values up
the stack
and that's the process of inserting a
value into a binary search tree
let's look at another fun problem which
is also a kind of a fun
depth first tree recursive problem
and the purpose here is to print all the
leaf nodes so we're looking at the same
tree
but we want to build a function that
prints out all the nodes
that we see here in the order from left
to right so 30
60 85 95 108 115 and 150.
now if we think about the recursion for
how this works mechanically
we start at the root node and we go all
the way down
and we hit a leaf node here so we would
print it out
and what i would do is i would basically
pop off the call stack and go to this
node
but i would immediately go to this
node's right subtree
and this would be another leaf node
because it has no children and i would
print this
and recurse up the stack and then i
would go back up to 80 and now go down
its right half
and here i would go down its left sub
half find a leaf node
return go down the right sub half find a
leaf node
return and this process just continues
and the order of
execution is really important to
understand here remember
if i'm going down the left sub half i
can't even consider the right sub half
until the left sub half has been fully
explored
and that's part of the property that
death first search
follows and we'll look at another dfs
example with a graph
in just a second so now i go down i
recurse down the left sub half
i find the leaf node i print it i
recurse back up
and do this all the way until i'm
basically out of leaf nodes
to find which brings us here
and now we're done
so here's the code for this and we'll
look at this to understand
how things get added on the call stack
as well in the
code but again our base case is
what happens if we pass in a null value
that's a pretty good base case right
because then we would just return
there's nothing to print if you just
pass in null
but we also have to think about the goal
the goal is to print the leaf node
and so we want to keep recursing until
we hit a leaf node
and the properties of a node being a
leaf node is that
there are no children and so this is
where we start to ask
okay if there are no children to the
left there are no children to the right
then i can actually evaluate the
underlying value of that node
and just return
now if we're not a leaf node then we
need to recurse down the left sub half
of the tree
which is what we're doing here and
if we have a right sub half to recurse
then we go down the right sub half
after the left sub half has been
explored so this allows
us again this is why we evaluate the
left hand side first
and then we go down the right hand side
recursively and we do that for all
recursive subtrees up until we're done
so let's look at the call stack and see
how this is executing what we're looking
at here
is the same program so
we have some code here print leaves
and it's the same code that we looked at
before so if the input root node is null
we just return we evaluate the left and
right
and this basically checks if a given
node is a leaf
and we print it and then we pop
ourselves off the call stack
now if we don't satisfy that then we go
down the left and right half of the
subtree
so using the same code that we looked at
for insertion i've actually built
up a tree to use so i have some input
with a bunch of numbers these are all
the numbers
that we were looking at before i believe
and it's just a random set of numbers so
nothing special
and we just insert them so i have a
function here from the previous example
called
insert node and it just builds us a tree
for us
and so now what i want to do is i want
to print all the leaves here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
add a break point here and we're going
to debug straight into it
and the first question i ask is is the
root node null
and the answer is no it's not null right
it's this first value
and so what do i do well i recurse down
the entire
left half of the subtree so remember it
starts at 100
and now i go down to the left and since
it's not null
i skip over this and now i just recurse
down the left half of the tree
and for that node again it's not null
and for that specific node i again
recurse down to the left sub half of the
tree
and i just keep going down the left half
i don't even explore the right half
until this left half has been fully
explored and you notice we just printed
out
the first leaf node which is 30. and
it's only until i
explored that entire subtree's left half
that i can now go to this other
subtree's right half
so i dive in here and now i go down the
right half
it turns out that the right half again
is just another leaf node
and so i can just print this value and
if i put a breakpoint here you'll notice
that we just keep printing
you know we hit nulls we hit nulls and
we print the leaves
and you can see down here this is the
leaf node evaluation that we're doing
and the reason i wanted to walk through
this animation is to just further
emphasize
that when we're thinking about the call
stack i cannot even consider evaluating
this expression
until every recursive call and every
sub call has been fully evaluated
once that holds true then i can start
unraveling
the right subtrees and i work from the
bottom up
and that's the idea for these kind of
dfs traversals that we're dealing with
this brings us to our last section of
algorithms that we'll be looking at
and we'll look at a simple example with
graphs and we'll just see
how similar working with graphs is to
something like trees
and we're going to look at a very
popular algorithm known as depth first
search
and the idea is that we start at a node
like a and we basically say we're
searching for a node let's say the node
we're searching for is h
and so i start from a and i say okay let
me get all the neighbors
and see is this my value so a is not my
value
so i go to my neighbor and i say b b is
not my value go to c
d is not my value but i get all my
neighbors
and this is at an interesting point
because i'm searching for h
right which is in the far half but when
i get my neighbors
let's say the first neighbor i get is e
and so i actually have to explore
down the depths of e before i even
consider going to h
and so i go down and i see e and now i
go to f
and now i have to look at all of f's
neighbors so the first neighbor i go to
is k
and if k had neighbors i would explore
all of those neighbors
but it doesn't so i can just pop off and
now i go to j
and back to f now i go to i
and back to f and i kind of recurse back
up the call stack
so now that i've explored all the
neighbors of
or i've explored one neighbor of d
i only have one unvisited neighbor left
for me to explore
and it's g so i go to g and i say is
this the value that i'm looking for
and it's not so i look at the neighbors
of g and i say is this the value i'm
looking for
and it is and this is the idea of depth
first search
and so we're going to look at a piece of
code and walk through it line by line
and see how something like this would
work recursively
we look at a piece of code like this and
we have the input node
and to avoid cycles which can happen in
graphs
which is different than trees we'll keep
a set of visited values
so we never want to visit the same node
more than once
and so that's what the visited set is
going to do and the goal
integer here is just the node that we're
looking for
so i know the graph we were just looking
at was letters but we're going to assume
that we're working
with a graph with integer values
and we ask our base case questions again
so think about the smallest thing you
could pass in if you pass in
an empty node a null node then there's
no way you could ever find the goal
because the goal is an integer value and
so here we would just return false
so this is a base case the other base
case
is if we've actually found the node so
let's assume the node you pass in
is the goal node then here we found the
node
and so we would just return true here
and this would imply that we found the
value that we're looking for
but let's assume that we haven't found
the value just like the example
the first thing that we need to do is we
need to aggregate all of the neighbors
from a given node and so we're going to
assume the node api
has a function call that allows you to
aggregate all the neighbors
and the first question we ask is have we
have we visited this node before
remember we want to avoid cycles and so
we never want to visit a node more than
once
and so if it's been visited we just
ignore it and we continue
but if it hasn't been visited then we
add it to the visited set
and we start the exploration and we ask
this question
have we found the node that we've been
working with
with this particular neighbor if we
found the solution then we can just
return
right away now if we haven't found the
solution
from this particular neighbor then we'll
continue recursing
through the rest of the neighbors
and it's at that point if we found it we
would return true
and this brings us to our last base case
let's assume that we've
traversed all of the neighbors and we
never found the solution
that would mean that the goal value that
we're looking for
was just never in the graph to begin
with and this brings us to our final
base case of just returning
false and this is a way to say hey i've
searched for this node
but it didn't exist in the graph it's
false
it did not show up in the search and
that's where we can terminate the
algorithm
i think it's important to spend just a
little bit of time talking about
optimizations that you can make
when using recursion and the first that
we're going to look at is
memoization and caching which we talked
about briefly when writing fibonacci
and the question that we're trying to
answer here is how can we speed up our
program
by pretty much storing things that we've
already recomputed
or computed for the first time so if
i've computed some very expensive
operation
and i have to recompute it again in a
subsequent recursive call
i want to check to see if i've done that
work already and if i have i'm just
going to return the result
instead of recomputing that operation
again
and the best way to kind of
conceptualize this is looking at the
fibonacci tree sequence
here we see that i'm doing f of 3 twice
and i'm recomputing f of 2 three times
and the question is why can't i just
compute f of two once
and then just reuse that value so i
don't grow these subtrees
and it turns out you can do that really
easily
let's look at the modified fibonacci
code notice i have a hash map here and
hash maps have this property such that
we can retrieve values
from the map in constant time access so
big o of one
and the reason is because the data that
we put into the hash map is hashed and
so we have constant time access
to the memory addresses in which that
data is stored
and so when i call the fibonacci
function the first thing i always do is
i say hey
does the cache have this value and you
can also notice that i've pre-populated
the cache with the base cases as well
now in the instance that the cache does
not have the value
i still go about the recursive call as i
had done
previously but i ensure that once that
recursive call has been evaluated
i put the result into the cache and then
i return my result
and this is a really key component
because the cache
is global right and so all the
subsequent recursive calls
are putting their results in the cache
and as things get added and popped off
the stack i can just keep
cross-referencing the cache
to see if i'm doing redundant work or
not and that saves me
a lot of computational power so that's
the idea of memoization and caching
and you can do a lot of this in a lot of
different situations
the next optimization i want to just
discuss is this idea of
tail call recursion optimization and
people usually refer to this as you know
tail call optimization or tail recursion
and the idea here is that basically the
compiler
in certain languages especially
functional programming languages
will optimize the number of stack frames
that get added to the call stack to
basically remove this idea of stack
overflows in a lot of scenarios
now the way that the compiler does this
analysis is it really looks at the last
function call
and it has to be a recursive call
and we'll look at an idea of comparing
these two things
and there's actually a response on the
computer science
stack exchange by this user and he gave
two examples
the first is this simple recursive
factorial function
and notice that the final return value
is a value multiplied by a recursive
call
now this is not tail recursive because
the return value is not
just the recursive call and so in order
for this to be tail recursive
optimized we need to modify to look
something like this
now if you spend a second to look at
this code you'll realize that
functionally it's doing the exact same
thing
but we've had to modify the parameters
to get to a point
where we can build a function that's
tail call optimized
and the reason it's optimized with this
tailcall recursive property
is because the final return value is in
itself just a recursive call
and it turns out in certain operating in
certain
languages in their compilers they've
implemented some optimization techniques
to exploit this property and reduce
stack overflows
now i just want to make a couple notes
on this the rule of thumb is to
always make your recursive calls be the
last instruction
nothing gets added to it just the
recursive call
and the other thing to consider is that
this is supported
mostly by functional languages but it's
not
inherent in languages like python and
java and even javascript
there are certain browsers for
es2016 that do support tailcall
recursion optimization for things like
javascript but it's not supported across
the board
and so as you're considering this
optimization technique
think about what language you're using
and think about you know the compiler
that you're using and where your code is
being executed to see
if this sort of optimization is
supported or not
so this brings us to our final slide
what's next and
when we ask this question it's really to
consider like how far do you want to go
in your journey of recursion and that
brings us to
another video that we'll have coming out
known as algorithmic mental models for
backtracking
and this is the entire notion that we
basically solve even more complex
problems
by looking at a decision space and
recursively going through and seeing if
our decision was good or bad
and backtracking to see if we can solve
the solution in a different way
and that's the next phase that i think
is important for understanding recursion
so thank you guys so much for watching
be sure to check out my channel
youtube.com thesimpleengineer and
connect with me on youtube or twitter or
linkedin
and i'd be happy to talk with you and
answer any questions you may have so
thanks guys for watching and have a good